khiến trị thị sô 20 ngày 20, 30 năm 2018 của tụ tưởng chính phụ về thuốc Để giờ thông sàn.
Thành phố Hàn Nội đang sư dựng lộ trình tiến tới chăm rất việc sử dụng xe 1 tô.
Cây gần máy trẻ bằng như liệu hóa thịt trong khu vực phành dài một kẻ từ ngày 1, 30 năm 2020.
Phu vực phành dài một vùng có tướng đường, trên khách chân, đây khu vực, xá đàn, ô trở dửa, hoang cầu,
đây là thành, cầu dưới, mởi, nhi tạm, in vụ, trên nha dọt, chân quan khảy, chân khách dơ, nguyễn khóa,
Đi qua các quận trung tâm như bà đình, khoảng kiếm, đúng ra, 2 bà trung và câu dưới.
Chỉ thiết cũng đặt mục tiêu hạn chế ô tô cá nhân sự dụng như liệu săng,
dâu trong khu vực vành đai một và hai từ ngày 1 táng 1 năm 2020,
tính tới mở giộng phạm vi cấm đến tòa mộ vành đai ba và năm 2020.
Chù chương này, nằm thịu ủ nhễm khổ khí,
tục đẩy phát triển vương tiển ra thông thân thiển với môi trường,
tưởng mức hiện thật khóa mục tiêu phát triển đô thị săng,
mình vẫn để chừng khai hiệu quà,
hành hội sẽ nghen kiêu các chính sách hỗ trợ người dân và giới nghiệp trình đổi từ phương tiển xử dụng săng dầu săng sẽ điệt.
Đông thời, thành phố cũng xem sẽ tạm mức tụi một số lại phi như liệu phi trước bà,
phi đang kiếp, phi biển số và phi trong giữa đối với phương tiển xử dụng như liệu hã thách,
tạo động lực trình đổi phương tiển phù hợp với định hướng xa thông xanh.
Bây giờ thực hiện đồng bộ các xảy pháp nếu trên vừa gó phần cải thiển môi trường đô thị,
vừa tạo nên tạm bứng chắc cho khoa trình dụi săng trong những vực xa thông bận tải thú đô.